miss MacGovern thank you for being with
us you served I believe in the CIA for
27 years how do you feel about what has
been revealed in this report yes 27
years and before that there's an officer
in army intelligence so I feel very
closely very close to these
interrogation matters the report is not
a surprise it is a reassurance that the
Senate can actually investigate these
matters is disgrace of course what they
have uncovered hopefully it will as
senator Feinstein says be an assurance
that this will not happen again I find
it appalling I found the comment that I
just heard saying that torture is always
wrong when i learned moral theology and
ethics torture was in the same moral
category as slavery or rape always wrong
and if that's not enough now we know
that it's not effective either are you
saying that what went on was very
different from prior to 911 in terms of
CIA operations well you know the adages
after 911 everything changed and that is
quite true here George Bush found a
willing accomplice in George Tenet head
of the CIA and the rest of the story is
laid out for the world to see today
because there have been comments from
other veterans saying well this was in
the interest of national security and we
did such things under the Clinton and
other administrations the assumption
there is that torture is effective the
head of Army Intelligence on the very
day that George Bush bragged about the
success of these enhanced interrogation
techniques the date was September 6 2006
Lieutenant General John kimmons before
the Pentagon said no reliable
information has ever come from harsh
interrogation techniques history has
shown that and the empirical evidence of
the last five years hard years
also shows that period end quote 19 or
2006 minus five is 2001 the first person
the United States government tortured
was an American citizen named John
Walker Lindh was captured in Afghanistan
it's it's really you know for an
intelligence professional to see that
our moral bearings were completely lost
at this nervous breakdown that we had on
9 12 it's very sad is there a risk very
that this report as some Republicans to
say would undermine the CIA and indeed
America's ability to operate in its own
security interest abroad well we
Americans say garbage I understand do
you British say rubbish it's complete
rubbish it says though al-qaeda and the
Islamic state didn't know before that
this had come on we know for example
that when the jihadists came into Iraq
in the mid you know 2008-2009 those
folks primarily were motivated by the
photos that they saw it Abu Ghraib and
what they had learned about enhanced
interrogation techniques so you know if
you want to keep a war going if you want
to have a very long line of recruiting
for jihadists torture is the
unmistakeably best way to do that